thanks to Ron DeSantis the immigrants
that he sent to Martha's Vineyard may be
staying in the U.S for good Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis made headlines for
chartering a flight from Texas to
Massachusetts in order to dump 50 Asylum
seekers in Martha's Vineyard as a
political stunt this may all have
backfire because the vexar county
sheriff Javier Salazar said that the
DeSantis migrants were victims of a
crime people who are Crime Victims or
witnesses to a crime are eligible for
something called a u Visa which allows
them to remain in the U.S Congress
created the U Visa with the passage of
the victims of trafficking and violence
protection act immigrants who are
willing to help law enforcement
authorities in the investigation or
prosecution of the criminal activity
could eventually get a green card a he
signed the certification forms for all
the migrants saying that they were
transported under false pretenses which
is the crime of unlawful restraint under
Texas penal code section 20.02 a person
commits an offense if he intentionally
or knowingly restrains another person
unlawful restraint can be a Class A
misdemeanor state jail felony or third
degree felony depending on the nature of
the offense so way to go Ron